et en cette fin de journée ça bouge le
président russe demande au sénat l'envoi
de militaires en soutien aux
séparatistes en ukraine du livreur crack
bonjour vous retrouvons direct de kiev
difficile de savoir qui est en train de
se passer dans l'est du pays
oui on voit des véhicules militaires
russes circulaient dans l'est de
l'ukraine mais en réalité cela n'est pas
nouveau les russes sont présents dans
ces régions séparatistes qu'elle
soutient depuis
2014 et ses véhicules convois peuvent
être des véhicules qui étaient déjà là
en tout cas la russie n'a pas reconnu
avoir envoyé officiellement des forces
depuis qu'elle s'est autorisé à le faire
ce qui est contenu dans le document que
vladimir poutine a signé hier soir on
reconnaissant l'indépendance de ces
pseudo république
une autorisation qui a été confirmée
aujourd'hui par le sénat russe je ne
savais pas que là la confirmation du
sénat était nécessaire je pense que les
russes font exprès en quelque sorte de
en fumée l'occident de faire en sorte
qu'on ne comprenne pas s'ils ont
officiellement envoyé des forces ou pas
le ministre des affaires étrangères
russe tout à l'heure aujourd'hui avait
dit qu'il n'avait pas l'intention
d'envoyer des troupes pour le moment
mais il semble assez clair que la russie
à l'intention de continuer à soutenir
les séparatistes dont elle vient de
reconnaître l'indépendance est très
probablement très bientôt dire
officiellement qu'elle les soutient avec
des forces qui seraient officiellement
envoyée depuis la russie mais en réalité
comme tout le monde en ukraine au niveau
du gouvernement et au niveau de
l'opinion publique le confirme elle
souligné tout le temps en réalité c'est
juste la l'officialisation de ce que la
russie était déjà en train de faire dans
cette partie d'une basse le vice
ministre russe de la défense parle d'une
armée ukrainienne déployés dans ces
régions de 60 mille hommes et deux
blindés lourds en tout cas à kiev du
liver le président zelensky remué ciel
et terre il a multiplié les contacts
avec ses partenaires ce mardi
oui volodymyr zelensky pas son temps à
parler avec ses homologues dans d'autres
pays et il a aussi reçu aujourd'hui le
président de l'estonie l'estonie comme
les autres pays baltes l'un des soutiens
les plus forts de l'ukraine qui
appellent toujours à ce que l'union
européenne dont l'estonie et membres
organisent un paquet de sanctions le
plus fort possible contre la russie
l'estonie frontalière elle aussi avec la
russie aussi ex membre de l'union
soviétique est aussi très inquiet par
rapport à l'activité de vladimir poutine
mais bien sûr l'ukraine regarde plus
vers les grands états de l'union
européenne la france l'allemagne et
l'italie pour voir quelle sera la
réponse de l'union elle a considéré
comme un très bon signe aujourd'hui la
décision du chancelier allemand olaf
schulze de suspendre l'autorisation de
mettre en
utilisation le gazoduc nord stream de ce
à quoi le cren appelé depuis déjà
longtemps et on vient d'apprendre que le
président américain joe biden va parler
à bientôt pendant l'après midi aux etats
unis et on s'attend de lui aussi
l'annoncé des sanctions contre la russie